hello hey it looks like things just went
from bad to worse
are you quoting Leon yeah cuz we missed
that cutscene but if you want know we
watched it last time didn't we I think
so
you can see where we're leaving off yeah
so do you member what happened last time
can you why yes you were really low
sorry
it's just straighten I probably just
have bad posture that's a classic Mary
thing so we had a lady in a dress and I
think it was your sister Amanda and she
had some straight-up nudie boobies and
she grew tentacles all over her body and
we killed her mate wait she fell there
you go screen look off yeah she had a
red button she had a red button she's
dead now and few instances where I
probably could have a bleep button last
episode and they said stuff like what's
going on here and they were like
wouldn't you like to know and then like
disappeared so like I know nothing about
why anything's happenings they never
tell me well they could tell you but
yeah they just continue to teachers not
to Elena because they need a MacGuffin
to get you through this weird plot hole
filled plot sure what's going to it let
me tell you this do you like it when I
do this thing where I that's a great way
but on the florence's yes like when I do
it cuz my um the top part of my toupee
moves ever so slightly it's got some
shiny hair physics so I'm running reload
my gun how's the audio sounding voice is
good I think it sounds fine
well mine does
this weird cut a little bit yeah but the
door closed before you cut the black oh
it's a lot you and I are in the same
boat now let's see that officially it
makes us partners and when were we not
in the same thing weirdo
you were just following me for fun for
the same boat knob of his sitting right
on top of us tell my joke Alina shut up
that's not an easy question to answer
both of you shut up
Thanks oh fudge we're both in the same
boat now I guess that makes you my first
mate you can laugh when you're done kill
the snake I understand will you kill us
Nate you take off its head oh I hate
snakes even in video games like don't
like the way they move I'm not gonna Oh
more coffins this one wait hold on I can
get in this one I'm lay down quick I
want to dress up it out I don't think I
can
that's what I do in real life I'm a very
people I understand let's go up here
alright hold on a second let's
so I'm led to believe by what I'm
looking at that someone rated these
coffins or they woke up so these are
actual zombies right like I mean either
that or the guy who raided this place
repositioned everybody and funny right
positions then laughed as he walked away
he was going for a Last Supper thing
here and this is the Jesus but and then
this one up here doesn't even have a
coffin or the one above him well these
are like our weirdly it's like you
mention Allah but also an orphanage they
just like shove them in the walls or
like a camp what yeah okay two questions
is it a buried in use it's the second
one that's where did with this
conception of orphanages to come from
cuz a bunch of people just shoved in the
walls all right explore that later and B
what kind of camp did you go to where
they show some mastics camp they put you
in walls to increase your flexibility
well everybody had to cook it worked did
it everybody had to UM you know it's
like oh oh I thought that's thing for
coming at me if you went to gymnastics
camp you would have been able to dodge
that okay oh I got it douche
a prayer to stay dead yes so this
doesn't make sense like they used to be
zombies created from biological weapons
now they're actual so how to comb the
zombies oh [ __ ] I just screwed it back
you know he's gross
check
I don't know hold on it's not why would
weights again yeah great
can't they like not get to us we've gone
about this all wrong I play myself oh
sorry
I almost got up I let go of L on exit no
I thought you were excited because that
Sandlot reference no but thank you for
recognizing it I watched that every 4th
of July which was what like I'm about to
go at this point exactly almost I watch
this year I play myself
Timmy Tommy takes all right we've gone
for far enough that's some fire what is
this about later we got higher up you go
I'm gonna observe these people oh you
can see my bots on screen right now
ah dang it crawling around up there and
I got nothing to do but if I have losers
more
sorry well I've been screaming I can't
really talk I had more time here in the
week I would show my screen off for free
why do you think I screamed the zombie
was like all up in my business hand I'm
down what do I do
turn off the fire naturally okay
somebody's coming from oh thanks it was
actually it wasn't a button it was well
it was but it was a guy turning a wheel
size to kill him like he had to just
turn it forever
yes it seems like poor engineering
Ouroboros isn't it set forth evidence of
kith and kin wait I think he's making
itself so just family tree
that's two things are you doing each
other fire back outs
what did you do it was nowhere here whoo
Simons and what did they say
so I took the ring out of the door I'm
led to believe okay and then it goes
back in the door what I guess we got a
Oh where'd you get that
Nina gave it to you I don't act like you
know what's going on do you listen not
paying it's in obviously I'll turn the
fire on wait wait don't act like okay go
do it
yeah do it
I hope you like fire charts skin he's
dead Oh do it again it would be like
beef jerky or something I hope you like
sirloin oh he's got a
a killing them are there more hard to
tell
taking a break I'm gonna get wait these
guys aren't dead [ __ ] I don't know are
they not dead of all that guy has a that
has a dynamite edible arrangements
oh it's slowly rotating of course was
why would the door open quickly edible
arrangement you laugh at the weirdest
like I say brilliant jokes that you
don't want no let's not get ahead of
ourselves
Oh spit on sounds like you got problems
oh we need fire I'm going I'm going to
turn on the fire we got like 80 oh I
need you to protect me okay oh you
buttholes you [ __ ] I need to turn the
fires got about to scream okay
oh he's got a screen
I'm not you okay the door all right the
door we want I turn it it's right okay
recover Elena you stupid idiot wow we
really fell through that woman just
stumbled our way through that check wait
it just shot really fast I couldn't have
opened that quickly game is dumb
did you miss that nice I might remember
the shark in the first reading evil yeah
that's sharks plural one big one so wait
is it like bard um within this rope it's
really obedient it doesn't line up cut
the line when it's waiting for burritos
at least the Sharks polite I'll give it
that that was weird
okay can we just put they've run out of
space for the people here's one well
this guy just came outside to get some
air inside emblem that's the same logo
as the ring in the door the Simon's
family when are we gonna fight this fish
damn it Janice we found it that the
sacred ruby of the Cylons family I'll
take the low I prefer the low road if
you know what I mean
they're the crevasse fill it I got it
Oh Oh God [ __ ] this guy well I don't
know what's happening up there but I'm
in this race it's Michael Phelps's dead
body I couldn't do anything about it
this kind of creepy I'm in this crawl
space in there I'm getting the [ __ ] out
of this water here with me oh god I have
like a pretty decent fear of Lake I
found the Ruby water and things that I
can't see any water yep gift me rotating
like this under the table I know how the
internet works it's me can i I was not
even close to you
help me don't you have any that was
lucky how the waters become 12 feet deep
all of a sudden I don't know I haven't
been where you're oh you're not crossing
the rope oh my god there's a lot of
people in here key shoot them
sure actually no oh wait and I had us
shotgun because I'm dumb all right so I
have a I have the that was pretty cool
oh but I forgot about me
in your haste to defend your love what
neglected yourself I just don't feel
that way about Elena
both how you got that third Chuck the
handle I see it it's like in the center
of my screen I'll snipe some dudes wait
wait oh I see him oh [ __ ] really shape
you this you did can you see me oh yeah
see if you can see people near me
can you get through now let me check yep
first I'm gonna stop oh they're spikes
that's coming out before sweet it's the
booths cute mine's way harder than yours
mine's like got a Oh hon let me get this
what's going on with your gift
look at mine okay so this is very right
there
yeah it's those spikes back there that's
way harder than your fan blades
to make sure nobody's behind why do I
get there's got to be a button you press
or something there's no way I could dive
across that maybe it's something I do
when we get underneath these things Oh
unless you like that guy's bad don't
[ __ ] lie to me
right like there's no action it's gotta
be a way to stop it you could [ __ ] okay
look I yeah [ __ ]
so we kill whoever's tearing them
Goodspeed you did it don't let me get
back on it breathing here well operated
by cranks including me are you dead
nope just grappling with Azam found it I
really need a greener Bible reading it
makes it work just okay good I don't
understand can we take the crank out of
the thing that we crate I am rotating
like oh wait whoops sorry I don't know
what [ __ ] like warned me uh no my bad
wait I don't want to be cranking that do
i I don't see why you would no no even
now across he's spitting at me
the spikes are done just ignore him and
go past that right but I need a crank Oh
so can I take it out of cannae inch oh
wait no hon you give me a crane I gotta
go oh I thought a shovel like oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] he's spitting at me they're
spitting at me
I'm just not sure they should
[ __ ] spitting at me it's really
I like thought I was dodging it but I
don't do it okay so I have a plan
oh he's got a helmet on I'm gonna die
all right obviously I just I need a
crank where is a crank on so I think I
might have a solution just give me like
let me kill this guy for you
you got sniper everyone please stop
spinning at me guys got some projectile
give it I just needed problem
they got like helmets on oh he's got a
key sweet I'll be afraid what I'm coming
why you and your [ __ ] helmet oh you dick
I'm gonna die up still no I'm gonna die
oh I really don't have a lot of time I'm
trying to see him with a sniper hate
this guy hate this guy I'm shooting the
other one alright I need you to go
through this gate now please go get over
all right there okay cool
and then I need you to open up your mind
before I die
[ __ ] oh he's got dynamite his back your
strange strange sad little man harsh
whoa look at my uterus
[Applause]
saved you like
but-but-but-but face you see that armor
eyes but so that's the same tactic I'd
go for leg but but but feast
welcome back stranger oh you get along
so well relationship is a direct
contradiction to our relationship no I
don't want to discard it
oh there's amble back here I can't pass
up so spray some stuff on my face I'm
ready to go okay
classic misdirection it's not
misdirection right oh yeah you think
you're gonna go through the door but you
go down perpendicular mm-hmm welcome to
the Center of the Earth
do you think we're actually there holy
[ __ ] we fell far they're suspiciously
okay we're just following as far as ISO
oh so okay yeah I feel like we hooked up
it's gonna bei Oh Nate it's just
stalking this wall yo how do I know
which one it is is it this one yeah what
it with what did the soldiers stab each
other with but what did the sandwich
soldiers stab each other with during the
Civil War been amazed did you make that
up right now like as we were talking to
each other well more like the more I
spoke out loud
you in your butt first
I'm advancing come down here with me
[Music]
noise
jump these gaps me yell alright what can
I pick up ammo and my audit how much is
it because is it because of these ok
that's why I waited Shh fire it in the
air well that like literally is also
wasting it like yeah like that would be
like shooting your gun into the trashcan
you know does that make sense the
purposes of this argument yeah like you
can place your a metaphor you can place
the bullet in the trashcan or you can
shoot the bullet into the trashcan well
what's what's more fun what's it
relieves more stress I don't know I've
never actually shot a gun into a trash
can before he fired a gun at all I
promise yes oh he threw his concrete at
another one he's got a dynamite he's got
a stick with some fire on it torch he's
got a wood he's got some wood with a
nail in it who's that Wow my health is
low I have one box left all right well I
will protect you
I haven't read ER by breath I'd love a
green herb it only just occurred to me
that Russell Russell Kurt Russell has
played both a Wyatt Earp and a Herb
Brooks in miracle are you serious I
can't pick this up I obviously don't
understand how ammo works is it's like
all the slots that I have ever see for
is taking up half of everything I have
too much c4 you're getting
perhaps I should use a c4 on them across
this bridge okay across this bridge when
we come to it
heads up heads up why I shot him six
times yeah do it do it let's go whoa
I hope you like death did I do it God my
health you did it
I obviously don't understand I see for
works every one bullet I fire makes or
noises alright I got it I got this one
do it
oh wait this guy's got a torch yeah I do
it anyway
oh I think that hurt me yeah well I'm
learning a lot about c4 right now
invented by uh mister for know Charles
Cunningham Chris nte chrysanthemum the
count of Cunningham Castle Charles c4
otherwise the fourth Charles afford was
like he's doing that thing where he runs
away again I've got you just jumped off
well did you see that I did what a
goddamn idiot please the undead oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's gonna scream call him at it
boys
the Qaeda's vaulted over us into the let
me use my c4 someone do that wood when
there was no pathway I'm gonna see for
this entire ship bloater dude whatever
they call them this game got it run oh I
don't got it listen Murray not supposed
to be on the bridge at that part [ __ ]
why are we still in the game we both
died [ __ ] that guy my c4
tricked
work let's try these about what killed
us what me using see oh we're right here
yeah no don't go up there you gonna run
you over I'm gonna watch this okay I got
it
that's weird and c4 is just floating
there do it oh he's dead oh wait so you
could pick it back up
I can't I believe so
let's go I don't think I can pick it up
I might be wrong I probably do it
well he's passed now no these are there
he's going sergeant he's right there
come here put the peanut butter dum-dum
stop it what did you learn do it yeah
please game so I don't have to wear
anything I have full health now on the
bright side so I should die more often
god I can't pick up any of this stuff
cuz I have too much c4 tedious arduous
other games I would use to describe this
section fun thanks
ooh oh wait for it wait for it god damn
it Johnny I got him No
why is there NATO ammo down here which
would be like c4 you later
so when you pick up a salt rifle ammo it
says NATO ammo what was NATO doing down
here and why are they using bayonets and
whatever year this was 2012 I feel like
we're learning a lot I'm gonna do
another one of these cuz they're really
fun oh man oh that's a longer bridge is
the other one okay
alright wait here
forget him I don't know I did get him
but he's still your over the weight
limit
came over that myself it it is but look
I never took Leon for a fat Shamer yeah
[ __ ] you Leon I have to agree with you
I'm just I agree with his I agree with
his work style that guy's pretty his
personal laughs up to him but hey yeah I
don't it
he's pretty excessive though we haven't
found my key in a long time like since
the beginning of the game are you saying
there's a helicopter coming up is that
what you're prepping for I just started
talking like Mikey oh say that doesn't
fit hey it's not him get over here oh
he's got to get okay the guy who left
get nope get oh I see what you're saying
sorry go watch me wait what's the price
where'd you go I watch me propel me
that's so [ __ ] awesome this is Moria
from Fellowship of the Ring this is do
you see what I'm doing
are you dying can you cover me please
get out of your inventory whoa man
cuz this would mean you disagree cut
away save you shoot the dead things
clawing in my ankles oh yeah I got you
dude listen they're pretty fast I'm on
the other side if it makes no signs of
life I don't think this gun is very good
for what you need it for oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
loaded it oh they will
I'm gonna try and help you no you're
good stay at us this is my fight No
oh shoot I got cha it's good it's good
I can't believe this guy's still alive
yeah yeah I was really good thing I
helped you 12-gauge shells no room I
just do like a grenades give me some of
those oh there we go
bonuses you got oh you like dropped all
these like trophies dynamite guy behind
you killed him please I did I do
pretty dope [ __ ]
I got all other one of these guys with a
hatchet and there's an emblem oh my god
[ __ ] wear a bell Sam I'm crossing the
bridge cool can you like yep
what have you done for me lately I'm
comment I'm trying this is like level
has all been all about you totally
diggin being selfish you've been working
up being more generous about all the
attention today I know are you in
trouble no I just am so lucky company
please
yeah no it's about me I have to ask your
help one more time before the day is
done you don't even oh this is as fast
it's halfway oh you can see a [ __ ]
please help me do not make me start over
I like essentials I really heard for me
to see them Oh got it nice thank you
good shot thank you
I was just I just want to make it like
stressful for the viewers like you know
I got you girl you know I got you hey
wait get up coffee
Oh shotgun shells why can't I pick them
up cuz your inventory is probably full
of c4
[Music]
you there's friendly wait since when is
there friendly fire also I just blew up
these stairs you see this sorry why I'm
serious I did not know a friendly fire
was on I'm sorry I'm gonna punch this
Boulder you know Chris Redfield let's
not get ahead of ourselves I really did
just [ __ ] you up yeah I look okay look
why is c4 friendly fire but nothing
elses there's continuity flaws in the
mechanics it's game bomb why am I
surprised inconsistent mechanic systems
that's gonna collapse no snake oh I fell
coming coming
Oh zombie yeah dodged dynamite nope
[ __ ] don't kill him [ __ ] yes yes nope oh
he does I didn't really do much to not
shoot him there so that was my fault
he's got a hatchet in him so it's not
that much of a threat I guess it's
actually kind of helping us
I had a pill I'm alright now it's a
fantastic song come with chameleon if
another zombie comes up wow this is just
as slow why is this so slow are they
serious oh no you keep going I'll kill
him
oh god we both let go we both have to do
this on ya come up in oh I have to hold
it here
so ya all doesn't make you to kill wait
it starts from the beginning no they did
they totally did this is some [ __ ]
can we go further no this is that this
will be you know the left one right I
hope so what the [ __ ] I'm not even
slowing it down [ __ ] gonna die I need
your help
get off of Lena and down why is this
part so stupid didn't anyone talk about
how bad this game is wasn't this
disgusts figure this out that can't be
expected oh that's cool Callaghan suck
abyss okay let's try to do this again
but what are we doing wrong is there hi
am i hitting the right button why is
looking grown so fast I'm going past if
another zombie comes out of nowhere I'm
gonna flip my lid blow my lid look how
good we are at this video game
oh I thought we'd I think we died no I
just have a feeling
Oh sorry wait don't you just appear
there after falling you did too this is
literally run Frodo oh my god stop
making me stumble
let me run let me do what you want me to
do uh what do we do here oh oh oh would
you go under his legs yeah that was cool
- mint - Kevin run [ __ ] you love to
reference Kevin Kevin but she doesn't
say run after she does the pigeon lady
Kevin but I need you to punch his folder
and when he lures him into Central Park
and then coax them in birds
she coats them in bird feed oh I thought
you meant the original so when she
forgets her kid and she's in the
airplane she goes I know it's just a
different quote that's all I think
speaking of which Macaulay Culkin is in
the movies all the feesh he's hiding for
the fee she would make a good Leone he
actually is kind of the real-life
equivalent of Leon Kennedy he visually
looks like him you know you could
definitely do it
imagine chris hemsworth with bangs
parted like that like dwight shrute
bangs how are you talking right now
guzzling water what do you want to eat
for lunch tomorrow so my sister got that
place in Flagstaff the mortgage is
really high but the property value is
through the roof huh Wow perform stroke
gonna just that stroke
this is like it's like we're in the
Olympics Leon you ever try to breathe
underwater it turns out we can't wait
tapping X or holding it I'm tapping hold
it won't do anything discover these are
the worst swimming controls I know games
are notorious for bad swimming controls
how long are we love to do this for
before we die I don't know but if that
gauge and the rights aren't breath they
are pretty do they practice there's
water there's air up here
[ __ ] I wish I would have known that
before you okay I'm almost there uh-huh
almost there oh this guy's gonna grab me
I feel like you don't have enough air oh
[ __ ] I don't know what we'll find out
god damn it god damn it I might drown no
no no I'm going go for it
fortune favors the bold uh-huh that's
what a lot of divers say before they die
you know I think I'm through I think I'm
through yeah it's like Tomb Raider I'm
looking at a dead where are you I hope
I'm not taking up this Airport I'm
actually really confused like where am I
going
would there be oxygen where are we going
I can't you go down toward me no no I
don't think so [ __ ] just go up toward me
you got you've got more got a little hat
with light on it but everywhere the [ __ ]
I am go this way
yeah it's for me uh it okay I see what
your problem is oh yeah right there go
to the light oh my god can you join me
up here please if you can't I'll get out
you guys it up here check out that
[ __ ] ass skull you either suck it up
all our oxygen what's that guy doing so
okay don't freak out there's undead
people that are about to grab our ankles
oh my god would there be oxygen in this
I know no way there's blood coming up
all right so yeah yeah okay so silver
lining it pointed us in the right
direction no he's there oh you're hurt
or something what was that
I don't know I'm just gonna follow you I
think I'm just guessing for Brett I'm
not gasping thankfully oh of course he
grabbed your hurt or something I'm
coming oh my god how is he alive he's
I'm fairly certain doggies need oxygen
to their brains okay wait
light go Niners help me help me oh okay
what if they're like under it and she's
trying to tell him what she wants to do
he's I don't know I can't understand you
sorry oh my god is that the Yamaguchi
2.0 Bluetooth Oh God
the fish the fish he got both of us he
came back for me
he was just helping us get to a better
place surviving a fat great oh all right
yeah that's a shark oh is it is that
what this is oh I think I should have
just died it's weird yeah be ready all
right I don't know what I was gonna do
now
okay I did square next it's up to you
now
man they took this is a cool-looking
boss but they ruined him where'd I get a
spear I pulled one out of him
click the logout from for oh [ __ ] what
Sheila stunts in [ __ ] sorry ok got it
what's going on on your end nothing yet
you haven't done how to do anything no I
have I had to rotate the stick once hold
off flesh that's for sure where am I
you got another one where I don't know
where I am you're in the fish's mouth a
lot yeah my cuz I'm seeing what you're
seeing right now they gave me a lot of
time to do that
they've been underwater this whole time
exerting pressure exerting like energy
haha what the [ __ ] do you want to like
why yeah no they have not given us an
herb in about 24 dog years
I got an herb I have I it's when you got
mad at me oh I have a first day spray
[ __ ] leave me when I got mad at you
because I like found an herb but I
couldn't fit all right like I can't
[ __ ] fit in here get out of here I
feel bloated today can you get those for
me
Lake wait there's an envelope here how
does that work because you can't get
that you have to play through the game
as both characters to get all the
emblems I wonder cuz that's like a 60
hour game I'm over here now definitely I
agree it looks like you could squeeze
through there in real life
like I thought it was one of those like
gameplay things were it was like yep
that's where I'm supposed to go where
those bars aren't yeah this games
apparently there's a lever way over
there this is really boring for you and
I don't you got this water going for me
and that's nice
shoot something over there it's waiting
for the record I might be missing
something well that's cool could just be
poor game design to make you wait that
long before I get the crank when I'm in
the water I wipe water off my face no I
need you here for this I did miss
something sorry
can I dive so can I go down there I'm
coming back just try to entertain people
for them tell us a joke Mary um what do
you get when you cross a centipede in a
parrot
no no what a walk jockey
what am I supposed to be doing um I'm
Susie telling jokes I think you're
supposed to lift these bars how do I
don't think I can come back over here
with you you went through that tunnel
right
oh I forgot to have a objective marker
even trying I am yeah I've been in a
water with a giant fish for like three
minutes okay
so Ellen why is it meet your partner on
the other side are you sure there's
nothing you can mean am I supposed to
give you something is that what you're
saying no no there's a fire over here
but I I don't think I can get up there
can i that'll be cool hold l1 soon it
shows you yeah see what but I need to
get past them busy bars I wish I could
just jump in the water and I'll go back
to the main area and see if there's
something I missed but I feel like
there's a fee in there pshh I said meet
you on the other side well I've got one
why did the baby cross the road I get to
his mother because it was a staple to
the chicken no well what am I supposed
to be okay let's think is logically you
need to open these birds right I agree
with that but why is it gonna be that
objective because that's where we're
supposed to go eventually when we meet
up right I agree so ignore that and like
find a lever yeah I mean I've been
looking for one I don't know what it
would pop up
hmm anyone ever told you that you're bad
at video games
probably not the yes so I see you come
up here look up look at me
I even landed some camera time no not
the way you're playing so I can shoot
that would be easy I'm gonna look at
your screen couple over Oh
how am I supposed to know the laser
pointer from earlier in the game
Oh laser has been so long since we
played the game last good call
Oh No fiche fiche I think that was the
door closing really gets fever looks
like more folks oh [ __ ] I'll shoot it
thank you thank you I've got him swim
Leon Leon Leon shut up
shoot its tongue or something shoot its
dick got it welcome thank you yeah I see
it
no literally did you kill it no I mean I
stopped doing killing that was
anticlimactic let me get down here oh I
did it okay I'm here oh my heart my
little Hawk can barely take it no more
these guys helping us out left and right
hey pretty good overall sniffing [ __ ] oh
there's ammo next to us
yeah we like been slippin slidin oh I
sorry I couldn't let you I was picking
up the Ameth game pretty good
well I don't
yeah reload you idiot oh we can't reload
your switch weapons
so side note you have to hold l2 reload
while you're going down the water our
idea at least for this already oh oh
you're supposed to hit those explosive
barrels like the alligator and the resin
evil dose but bad if you like falling
how did they'd roll
you know what kind of core strength that
would take oh [ __ ] I'm out of ammo for
that
O'Shea Street oh man you dead I think so
oh my god like 45 minutes in time to
move on to Resident Evil 7 are you
getting seconds game you got a far less
fun episode than I have I I mean I'm
okay I think it's pretty dull to like do
QuickTime events this often for those
types of endings I think it's pretty
disappointing okay we're out though damn
really makes you think doesn't it the
water feels good on my this is the only
part of my body exposed it looks really
pretty though that's what they did in
Raccoon City did I tell you I was a
Raccoon City partner Oh Simmons why is
there one Abbott earlier Simmons Crest
Simon veiny palms kind of hunt again
anyway we can find out where he went
don't look I've got a tail on him he's
on his way to the airport right now
where his private jet is preparing to
leave for China
China that's near Germany that's in
Europe Hitler a new way thought that but
B virus verb Boros yeah a progenitor
yeah which might be the same thing no
progenitor was the flower thing if a
porous nose in this game going to listen
you never look at a woman's pores listen
as the game seems intent on showing me
her pores Elena I'm gonna take you a
film gonna take a photo of this sunset I
think you should see it give you a
little foundation your pores they're out
of control
your eyes are demonic we're going to
China
[Laughter]
that's the deck for this episode on
YouTube we're going to China
God he's cool he's my accurate China's
where it was the beginning you got an
s-rank oh no Helene is it no you gotta
nuts rank but I feel like you let me
down because you took so long at the
time my clear time ended me with a lower
rank do some upgrades and then you want
to calling it up calling it up alright
when you order dinner do you ever say
should we get some apps no sure I did
once and then I put a gun to my head and
pulled the trigger
all right sighs room for one more I
think I have enough money for do you
[Music]
I've eaten dinner with you before I've
never heard that at least I hope I
haven't because if I heard it I would
have slayed you in terms of like trying
to shame you in front of people what do
you want marry apps excuse me ma'am
sir what do I see your manager my friend
needs an app and I have no idea what
that is I would like an appetizer she
wants an app I'd you should help her out
because I don't know what to tell her
I'm so dumb I don't even I didn't even
want Mele and I got mail a level-two I
like haven't been thinking at all oh I
see I'm gonna do crits yeah really
you wasted a lot of skill points I I
know how do I obtain critical hits
firearm power sweets equip that item
drop increase oh I'm so disappointed
drop increased label myself I can't get
firearm there's only one level of item
drop increase defense that one recovery
strengthens your partner's backs when
you are near each other hmm
we're not often near each other oh [ __ ]
so I field medic you'll give me a few
health tablets when you rescue me
that costs 1200 and I only have 10,000
cuz or that cost 12,000 I only have
10,000 because I made a purchasing error
remember when I bought two guns in the
last games yep of the same kind they get
two body armors oh yeah I could only
wear one imagine though if I could have
layered them I've been good all right
I'll get defense level to sweet
I am wait I can't why can't I do it why
is it locked
give me all right cool
they did it
spoiler no where's the outro of his GD
video I'll see you next week Resident
Evil 6 it's loading Rana please to China
watch this for a teaser we're going to
China
we're going Mike Chang to chose me a
little height it's not a video of great
ad living space
hi hey girl
I took a Dookie in the bathroom
fantastic ad-lib a try it up
wouldn't stop sentence and trying to
grow up go to sign to grow me a little
bit is this supposed to happen on a
plane is my first flight it's a huge
plane
it's being flown by zombies more like
air force done guys cigarettes coffee
please buckle your seatbelts your
captain just turned into a zombie just
no place for that man who why is he
talking about the Cathedral this is a
crisis you idiot